-Welcome back. We are here
with Lewis Black right now.
Lewis, you're a great comedian
who's known
for your strong opinions
about all kinds
of different topics.
So with that in mind,
it's time to play a game we call
"Wheel of Opinions."
Here we go.
-♪ Wheel of Opinions ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
I'm gonna hit this button here,
which will activate
an opinion topic generator.
-Okay.
-It'll land on a random topic,
and whatever it is, you just
give your opinion on it.
-No problem.
-Here we go.
Let's do this.
Here we go.
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, cooking for yourself.
That's -- Look.
You don't cook for yourself!
Okay? Because that's
the road to insanity.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-I'll tell you why.
-Yeah.
-Fractions.
Okay?
Any recipe is for a family --
a nice family of four,
not for some miserable
aging prick.
You got to take 1/16th
of a thing of cumin?
That's not -- That's not a --
That's a formula for a stroke.
[ Laughter ]
-Too much math. Too much math.
Here we go.
-Who wrote the music?
Oh. Vaccines.
-[ Audience "oohs" ]
-Oh. "Ooh!" "Ohh!"
I'll tell you this.
I've been triple vaxxed.
If I can fill my bathtub
every day with the vaccine,
I'd hop right in it.
I would -- I would wash myself
in the vaccine.
I got no problem with it.
Look. We live in a country --
I don't understand
why people don't do it.
They're taking supplements.
We'd scarf them down.
We spend billions of dollars.
We eat them -- We eat
supplements like they're candy.
CBD oil, for God's sake.
It comes from a weed
at the side of the road!
And people are like,
"Oh, chuggy, chug, chug."
I take something
called ashwagandha.
It's an herb
that comes from India.
It's supposed to calm you down.
Doing a great job!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-Oh, my God.
Let's get --
[ Beeping ]
-Oh. Bean bag chairs.
If you buy a bean bag chair,
something is so wrong with you.
[ Laughter ]
Why would --
It's a bean bag chair.
You don't -- You cook beans.
You don't sit on beans.
Okay?
-God.
-When I was in college --
and we were doing a lot --
I was doing a ton of pot,
just tons of it.
And I'd sit --
You'd sit on a bean bag chair.
You never thought,
"Oh, I'm comfortable."
What you thought was,
"I'm gonna get a knife,
I'm going to open this up,
I'm gonna make
some [bleep] dinner."
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know if I can take it.
I'm going to have a stroke.
Okay.
[ Beeping ]
-QAnon. Oh, yeah.
Another good group.
[ Laughter ]
They recently,
a while back there,
they decided they're going to
go to Dealey Plaza,
which is where Kennedy was shot.
And they went there,
a bunch of them,
because they were gathering
to meet up with --
John F. Kennedy Jr.
Was going to show up.
And then they were
going to go with him,
and John F. Kennedy Jr.
was going to show up
with our former leader,
and then they were going to go
to the White House,
and then they were gonna tell
the President to leave,
and he would, of course, leave.
And...
And, uh --
-Yeah.
-I -- What's -- It's --
[ Stammering ]
How -- How crazy do you
have to be to think that?
I had called John Kennedy Jr.
the day before,
and he said, "I'm not coming."
-[ Laughter ]
-He answered the phone?
And he said, "There's no way
I'm going to come to that."
-He said, "No."
-He said, "There's no way
I'm going to do that."
[ Beeping ]
-Oh, here we go.
-This music is spectacular.
-Thank you. I wrote it
on my phone, believe it or not.
Oh, social media.
-Social media, which goes back
pretty much to QAnon.
We can combine those two
in a way.
Because I have such a joy
about social media.
What -- I've learned one thing
from social media,
and QAnon kind of proves
what I'm going to say,
and that is this --
if you make something up
and then you believe
what you made up is true...
then you are crazy.
[ Laughter ]
And -- And if you read something
that someone had made up
and you believe what they made
up is true, you're crazier.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-That is Lewis Black!
Lewis Black.
Lewisblack.com.
Anything Lewis Black.
Catch him live on
his "Off the Rails" tour.
Check out his latest special,
"Thanks for Risking Your Life."